Miami da la bienvenida desde este
viernes efectivamente sus duelos
eliminatorios México y Puerto Rico a ver
hoy el primero de los dos partidos de
cuartos de final que tendremos en la
Florida en donde también se van a jugar
las dos semifinales y la gran final La
próxima semana es por eso que conectamos
con nuestro enviado especial Rafael
Pérez oquendo quién estará cubriendo ese
tramo final del clásico mundial Rafa hoy
viernes México Puerto Rico se van a unir
a Cuba y a Japón como el tercer
semifinalista de ese certamen los
mexicanos han ido de menos a más en el
Torneo mientras que los boricuas vienen
de perder a Edwin Díaz una de sus más
grandes estrellas
Sí una de sus principales cartas o Juan
una un desgarro en el tendón rotuliano
de la rodilla derecha es lo que comentan
los médicos que tiene Edwin Díaz es
también una baja sensible para los mix
de Nueva York Juan ya vimos como salió
en silla de ruedas y bastante adolorido
de el terreno de juego Juan te comento
también hablando de picheo que Julio
Urías será quien tome la pelota por
México la estrella de Los Ángeles
Dodgers también también importante decir
que Puerto Rico aún no ha revelado su
carta todavía no se sabe quién tomará la
pelota por Puerto Rico Entonces otro
dato importante a tener en cuenta es que
en 2017 es cuando único se tiene
registro de enfrentamientos entre México
y Puerto Rico nueve por cuatro terminó
en aquella ocasión lo que la balanza
inclina la balanza inclina a la victoria
sobre los
también importante hablar de Randy a
rozar en el cubano nacionalizado
mexicano que está encendido Juan está
bateando de 14 veces al bate siete Siete
hits por lo que tiene un gastronómico
averaje de 500 Juan a Rosa arena que ha
estado muy activo celebrando esas buenas
actuaciones que he tenido en el campo
Rafa todavía tenemos a cuatro equipos
latinoamericanos en esta pelea México
Puerto Rico Venezuela y Cuba por lo
menos en esta sede de Miami una de las
cuatro sedes de esta primera fase del
clásico mundial hemos visto mucha
alegría en la grada Cuál es el sentir
allá en la Florida con tanto
protagonismo de la región
precisamente vine a este parque es un
parque Juan en Florida donde los
latinoamericanos hacen mucho ejercicio
mucho jogging y hasta ahora no me han
querido no han querido comentar de
béisbol lo que están acá no hablan de de
béisbol pero está el ambiente muy
colorido como es en la Florida ayer
Precisamente en los enfrentamientos en
el entrenamiento de Puerto Rico sonaba
imagínate en el audio central del
estadio canciones de salsa vallenato
incluso Tengo una bola acá en la mano
esta bola es para demostrarte Juan El
Poder que tiene Puerto Rico al bate
Fíjate que en las prácticas Yo estaba
sentado en el left Center en la segunda
grada y ahí cayó esta bola en una
práctica de bateo Imagínate cómo sería
entonces en el juego de verdad que se va
a desarrollar los fanáticos muy
respetuosos de manera disciplinada
asisten al estadio todos tienen todos
tienen y brindan por el triunfo de su
bandera
y realmente repito la palabra es
colorido Juan colorido Florida es
colorido por la diversidad de
nacionalidades latinas principalmente
que acá ha concluido